general petraeus used to be the director
of cia 2000 and your workout partner in
my workout i write about this so i i
loved and hated those workouts with
petraeus because he is a physical
beast he's a strong fit
at the time 60 something year old man
let me take a tangent on that because
he's coming on this podcast oh excellent
man so uh can you say
what you've learned from the man uh in
terms of
or like what you
think is interesting and powerful and
inspiring about the way he sees the
world or maybe what you learn in terms
of how to get uh strong in the gym yeah
or anything about life two things right
away and one of them i was going to
share with you anyway so i'm glad that
you asked the question so the first
is
that
on our runs and man he runs fast and we
would go for six mile runs through
bangkok
and uh and
he talked openly about i asked him how
do you keep this
this this this mystery this epic
mythology about your fitness and your
strength how do you keep all of this
alive with the troops
and he had this amazing answer and he
was like i don't talk about it
myths are born
not from somebody orchestrating the myth
but from the source of the myth simply
being secretive
so he's like i don't talk about i've
never talked about it i've never
exacerbated it i just do what i do and i
let the troops talk and he's like when
it's in favor when it goes in favor of
of discipline and loyalty and commitment
i let it run if it starts getting
destructive or damaging then i have my
my leadership team step in to fix it but
when it comes to the
the mythos the myth of him being super
powered soldier that's what he wants
every soldier to be so he lets it run
and he was fanta it was so enlightening
when he told me when there's a myth that
benefits you you just let it go you let
it happen
because it gets you further without you
doing any work it costs no investment so
the catalyst of the virality of the myth
is just being mysterious and and that's
what cia does well to go back to your
first question what does cia do they
don't answer any questions they don't
say anything and wherever the myth goes
the myth goes
whether it's that they sold drugs or
used child prostitutes or whatever else
wherever the myth goes they let it go
because at the end of the day everybody
sits back and says wow i really just
don't know
now the second thing that i learned from
petraeus and i
really am a big fan of petraeus i know
he made personal mistakes you don't get
to be that powerful without making
personal mistakes but when i worked out
with him the one thing that that my uh
the one thing that my commanding officer
told me not to ask about he was like
never ask the general
about his family
i'm a family guy so as soon as i met
general petraeus
one of the first things i asked him was
hey what was it like raising a family
and being
the commander of forces in the middle
east like you weren't with your family
very much and the thing i love about the
guy
he didn't bite off my head he didn't
snap at me he didn't do anything he
openly admitted that he regretted some
of the decisions that he made
because he had to sacrifice
his family to get there relationships
with his children
uh absentee father missing birthdays
missing we j we all say we all say how
sad it is to miss birthdays and miss
anniversaries yadda yadda everybody
knows what that feels like even business
people know what that feels like
the actual pain that we're talking about
is when you're not there to handle your
13 year old's questions when a boy
breaks up with her or what you're when
you're not there to handle the bloody
lip that your nine-year-old comes back
with from their first encounter with a
bully
those are the truly heartbreaking
moments that a parent
lives and dies by
he missed
almost all of those because he was
fighting a war that we forgot and we
gave up on 20 years later right it's
he's so honest about that um
and it was really
inspiring to me to be told not to ask
that question and when i broke that
guidance
he didn't reprimand me he just
he was authentic and it was absolutely
one of the big decisions that helped me
leave cia on my own in 2014. and he was
honest on the sacrifice
you make
the same man the same man who just
taught me a lesson about
letting a myth
live that same guy
was willing to be so authentic about
this personal
mistake
you